now the day after world leaders pledged
to give more than 7 billion pounds for
Syrian refugees here's a story of aid on
a much smaller scale the dirty girls of
lesbos is a charity that collects washes
and then redistributes the wet clothes
that migrants discard when they land on
the Greek island and with me now the
person that set up that charity Allison
Terry Evans thank you for coming in this
morning but where did you get the idea
from it was simply a matter of I was
there I had actually been asked by
somebody in LA to take photographs but
immediately I saw that they were clothes
being discarded and thrown out and so I
just couldn't see that happen these are
perfectly good clothes that people have
worn and so I started to pick them up
and I looked for a commercial laundry
found it and so these days we wash about
three thousand kilos of clothing a day
and plus blankets up to three thousand
blankets per day that's an awful lot of
washing isn't it it's an awful lot of
question how much does that cost on on a
daily basis they've been able to break
down that cost something like ten
thousand euros a day and we raise money
from people all over the world who give
money who believe that that those
clothes shouldn't be in landfill and
that returning the clothes to the next
refugees who are coming in gives them a
sense of self-respect because they're
able to choose clothes that are more
than modesty levels and more the sizes
that they need and how are you able to
get people to go around and collect the
clothes are they coming from from all
over the world or or they aver anyway
there are volunteers on lesbos who come
from all over the world who just give
their own time because they believe that
they need to be there to help the
refugees because the governments are not
there so individuals are there to help
people and so from amongst those people
are very enthusiastic about being dirty
girls and we get messages from all over
the world people asking us can I be a
dirty girl and they come and work with
us is this a case of very little helps
mean you've got the politicians who are
there their job is to solve the crisis
in Syria
but you know everybody can play a part
and this is just a small way of doing
that everybody can play a part
absolutely and I believe that this is my
part and the women who work with me and
the men who work for me every individual
who comes to lesbos does it because they
know that they can make a difference by
being there other people can't be there
so they will send money to help pay for
the clothes we have a Facebook page
which is dirty girls of lesbos and it's
very important to put Avila's vos in
there you mentioned that the government
had they been supportive in your
activities or what what sort of feedback
have you got from that from the
government we don't see the government
involved with the refugees in this boss
at all if a government minister happens
to have come to the island at all from
anywhere suddenly there are no refugees
and what sort of feedback have you got
from the refugees that you've helped
with giving them fresh clothes they
really like that we have the respect for
them that we're not throwing their
clothes out they like that their clothes
are going to be given to somebody else
restoring some dignity to them Allison
thanks very much coming in and let us
know what you're doing thank you